like what your butt is writing my face
how are you dude hey guys I'm Ryan right
hey guys I'm Ariel usually you're
talking about salamander as in the fish
today we're moving today you're a
mermaid why cuz we're gonna watch the
honest trailer for The Little Mermaid
they're gonna be the Little Mermaid in
the real Little Mermaid movie as well as
MJ in the next bedroom I think it's
gonna make a lot of people happy
yeah you'll be great stuff look at dusty
part of my boobs like come on who
doesn't want to see part of petitioner a
petition the boobage
in 1989 the same year that Taylor Swift
was born the world met it even though
you're a girl whose songs got even more
stuck in your head
The Little Mermaid travel under the sea
to the musical a fascist kingdom of
Atlantica where some fish are allowed to
swim free while others are forced to
drag the ruling class around in their
chariots voyages their own bodies as
instruments and we Ariel a half-naked
fifteen-year-old have in firm order
follow her little fish out of water
story and falls in love with the human
Prince Eric because he's hot very
handsome beautiful the only thing
swimming in their way is the most
clearly evil villain in the Disney
Pantheon Ursula see which doll she's a
demon an old witch it keeps the tortured
souls of her victims in her front yard
eat seafood and hates Ariel's whole
family but none of that will stop Ariel
from trading away your voice for a pair
of legs at a 72 hour time limit to
French a stranger he is quite a catch
isn't it get swept up in a fantastical
romance where love conquers all is my
love you mean acting like a clueless
mute threat to America I would make out
with you and enjoy the vintage Disney
classic with an equally vintage message
for today's young girls look pretty
you're gonna look too Beast you look
wonderful
but without my voice okay your books
you surround yourself with friends were
dumber and fatter than you and if you're
not happy with the contract you sign
without even reading if I'm not say to
murder the person who outsmarted you so
strap on your fins for the musical you
can't help but sing along to featuring
songs like the Dumber mates are the
obligatory
feelings all these warring bad guy songs
but to move the blood long the villain
has to have a soul shouldn't you ask for
consent for song to resist it the
traumatize your kids are killing he's
telling me [ __ ] we show children see
even though the heroes are
thing is messed up as if that is alright
and the one we're about to get stuck in
your head
official
story cheese will seashells why delet it
person thank you and why uni moe
the little waistline this movie would
have played out way differently for top
F was a fish instead looks like really
bad morning yeah absolutely that like
those animated pornos they make I'm like
ones based off Disney characters I
forgot what the John was called but yeah
I've seen it before never turn me on you
know what I love about honest trailers
when you see it in a funny way yet
they're like making points that you're
like I never yeah never realize that
yeah it's pretty intellectual they do
more than nitpick like they point out
suffer I'm like huh
how could I have not seen it yeah it's
not just like cheap like they did some
cheap jokes but obviously they do they
also do their research cuz everything
just as are they save I can't talk today
well I think they say it's really
because I don't have school so I'm
really good day Netflix like they do the
songs they really do get that down of
like the cliches and how they all go I
didn't realize you know the Little
Mermaid is really a lot about looks yeah
I know it is like that it really is
they're showing you these clips and
you're like holy [ __ ] okay what if area
was just some average like I don't know
blonde chick strolling up on that beach
and uses like a whatever just another
yen they emphasize it a lot they do like
they were just like user looks she falls
in love I don't lust
exactly Wow I feel like I'm learning a
lot about the little mermaid right now
they could do like a very serious
adaptation do you know the real story of
the little mermaid know educate me I'm
about to blow your mind okay okay she's
at blow all right you're gonna do
anything
yep demo is actually based in Denmark
and the little mermaid ends up selling
her voice obviously the same way to the
sea which which I think to see which
might even be her dad's like her aunt
like her dad's sister okay
and so they that's why there's so much
hate for her family she like cuts out
her tongue it's like really morbid
and then she tries to get Eric to fall
in love with her but he ends up not he
ends up falling for another girl well
she has no tongue so what happens it was
the scene which gave her another
proposition like either you kill him or
he falls in love with you so then
because even falling up there she would
have to kill him in order for her to
live but she ends up just committing
suicide yeah do-do-do-do-do-do-do to him
has really set the mood I'm sorry
she's supposed to turn of like sea foam
or something oh I'm gonna blow your mind
with this little mermaid story okay
you're ready to get really depressed
about a trip but this story you grew up
on well I'm Cinderella the freakin
stepsisters I'm cutting off like her toe
is just a fit then shoot I don't know
the true stories I prefer to keep the
disney images in my mind like a smart
person does right guys
read i watch an occasional documentary
about the porn industry or something
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can subscribe to salamander Sally
Shamu does a lot of [ __ ] on there if you
like Little Mermaid subscribe to my
channel yeah cuz it's all based around
that yeah pretty much
why haven't you watched this movie
that's that's his actual name clever
hey guys love your channel usually I'm
not a huge fan of crude sexual humor but
you are the exception
ah you are kind of my exception that is
so cool that I can be you know like the
guy you could do crude humor like I
could talk about dicks and [ __ ] and
it'll be okay with you like you know
[ __ ] and con any word you really can
think of this is a Little Mermaid
trailer that we really decided that is a
catchy title man um I kind of envy you
for coming up with that what the [ __ ] is
your channel about that better not just
be a cool name you better back this up
with some cool [ __ ]
it's a page only eleven likes what the
[ __ ] man I thought this would be a lot
cooler yeah you know what I like it
everyone liked this guys page because he
has a clever
and I imagine clever stuff is in the
works Josh isn't Josh Martin I know I
try to be nice nowadays that's Christmas
you know after Christmas is back to the
same old [ __ ] [ __ ] Josh Martin hey
bro like your vids you should drop me a
shout out not only for something tear
things I know they were selling to your
channel but also liking your page just
saying that takes a lot of commitment
Josh I like this dude Josh this is a lot
of commitment my friend dude you better
you better stand there because we we got
to work through this it's a relationship
we're forming now subscriber to awesome
youtuber I am 50,000 subscribers now
after all RV I am I am got to share the
wealth you know that comes with 50,000
subscribers you really got to humble
yourself at this time of the year for us
as you can get ahead of yourself you
know anyway Josh Martin you haven't
Merry Christmas shindig am killer 66
this is legit one of my favorite
channels because of your very sarcastic
humor sounds like I'm winning over
people with crude sexual jokes and
sarcasm AC gotta at least you probably
got your pantry hey well you got the van
trailer reaction there are not a lot of
people who have that kind of make fun of
social issues humor like I do
oh and drop what's it what is that what
people saying drop a shout-out yeah must
be a rapper thing I don't know drop a
shadow
I mean I'm gonna start saying it now I
know it I'm asked every time I watch a
video sooner or later oh I ask ah i'ma
ask every time I watch of it so sooner
or later you're gonna have two extra
well we did yeah XD for extreme dick
that's what this guy has [ __ ] again
killer he's laughing motor car language
Sally I've seen a documentary or two I
know what I'm talking about I'm glad
this is your kind of channel my friend
he says he make me make fun of social
issues you know like racism and and what
else is a social issue these days well
we just talked about in this email right
seeing too skinny ain't too skinny for
me
and for young children that they should
be pretty in order to succeed in life
that's what this subscriber has really
taught me today's we are making a big
difference in society
we're like a modern-day Jesus Christ in
a way you know spreading the good word
to embrace dick and [ __ ]